I think in order to learn the language,
it's important to know a little
bit about the cultural background.
In order to learn that, I think you
need to seek out the people who
are interested in sharing it with you.
And I think that's probably
the most important part is to be
culturally aware and respectful of what
people are willing to share with you.
So for example, I was not culturally
sensitive when I was thinking
about my thesis topic.
I wanted to bridge the gap between my
undergrad thesis on native language and
its effect on my identity and tech since
I'm currently in Computer Science.
I wanted to bridge that gap and where
I was I wouldn't say disrespectful,
just not going about it the right way.
Usually you're invited by somebody.
You're invited to somebody's home and
it's about just being in
that space with that person and whatever
they're comfortable sharing with you.
Like an elder, the person who I was
wanting to speak with was an elder.
And I spoke with his son and
he's like, you can't go in there and
just ask questions and
expect them to be answered.
And that's exactly what
I was intending to do.
And after talking to him
a little bit more I understood.
And all the knowledge that
I wanted to gain from that
conversation was not going about
it in a culturally sensitive way.
And that's me, within the tribe,
another tribal person,
there are, I want to say, regulations.
What can you do, and what can't you do?
And what I was doing
was not appropriate.